hello and welcome to video playing coo
coo coo coo that's early that's a very
early Quincy to interesting maybe try in
a closed way that a wide solution is
extremely solid I mean you just play
them from fulfilling in reverse and with
my night over the on f6 i'm also not
able to play the most aggressive
continuation or interesting
if I take him we should take a for Scott
c5 again so I think it's an interesting
you will go be three now and Holly
wasn't a gradient very difficult for me
to prevent prevent this before in the
non one you still has to break down my
position but this I mean not a director
take it anyway stepping out of the
default the thing it's a very static
position wait we only maybe have some c5
business for Bishop b5 that could work
where I can carry check yes
97 probably he's got the bishop pair but
that is not that important here because
of the closed nature of the position
maybe you maybe can play later at night
moves and a 4 and so on that will take a
long while okay my bishop sucks it
really does
okay can i activate this Bishop somehow
what they also would like to get rid of
his room but don't know it have an easy
way to do that probably not most of the
night
rupee ate a 757 am is my very
attractive-looking idea all that really
sucks yeah I can yeah it's got this G
for life for lineup b5 yes playing this
is fine just just exactly how you need
to do it
if I'm not so sure about to be honest
because this is now that's getting very
closed now maybe he can go see 59 no no
no that doesn't look he cannot go see
five take a 665 am stopping the porn i
think maybe not maybe not but I think I
do
yes to take is if he takes a seven and
firmly cannot wanted why does that work
is that really that great I'm not sure
here I'm America and I can play c5 her
shortly and simply block everything I
mean it's extremely ugly chest-high
morning don't get me wrong but it might
still hold yeah I will pull out but I
probably cannot win okay after this
what's wrong I have to go to the seven
anyway play 60 I unfortunately missed
this idea I get the project check check
check check check
happy shipped assembling b3 and almost
okay maybe that was a bad move I was a
bad move what did I do that okay check
check yeah okay I should have won this
but with the time a draw is not totally
terrible yes game drawn and you
construct a meter I guess you can't now
I should have probably won't even with
the time situation but I kind of lost
the plot a little bit them yeah and a
position totally sucked of course the
whole time he just he just miss played
it somehow
I mean here why just just dominates
proceedings I just have some kind of
fortress what Knox with that maybe he
just should take it I felt like maybe I
can block area his bone structure is
extremely ugly enough I have someone
some outposts but I had just extremely
extremely ugly now he didn't do a bad
job I just think it sounds somewhere
here it did it evaporates somewhere
somewhere here yeah no I get this and
from here should probably win but i
didn't i didn't manage i mean it was a
bit of a scramble there now i really
miss played the the early opening here
this Bishop takes aphorism is a bad
decision I should probably add an engine
is right yeah a four is good if I can
that what the engine gives hear this
this closes 9p a door this is quite good
again now with the ponyo sorry with the
pawn here you cannot play v3 all that
easily and this looks yeah let's say
equal that that was just better for item
that was a bad strategic decision yeah i
was extremely one-sided game ok guys
thanks for watching